welcome back to CBS morning's legendary
journalist Bob Woodward is the author of
more than 20 books about American
politics and current affairs now with
the Trump tapes Woodward is doing
something he has never done before he's
releasing all 20 of his interviews with
former president Trump this is in an
audiobook the wide-ranging interviews
conducted mostly between 2019 and 2020
cover topics like Trump's relationship
with dictators and autocrats here's a
listen
I get along very well with erdogan even
though you're not supposed to because
everyone says what a horrible guy but
you know for me it works out good it's
funny that the relationships I have the
tougher and mean who they are the better
I get along with and you'll explain that
to me someday okay but maybe it's not a
bad thing
now these tapes also reveal the former
president's lack of urgency responding
to the covid-19 pandemic in real time
this is what he told Bob Woodward
was there a moment in all of this last
two months where you said to yourself ah
this is the leadership test of a
lifetime no
no I don't take responsibility for this
we're getting very good marks from the
governors we're helping the governors
because you know it's a local problem
you can't solve that federally
they also provide insight into his
apparent view of the presidency like
this exchange about a speech that he
says he wrote
everything's mine
the Trump tapes is being released by
Simon and Schuster which like CBS is
part of Paramount Global we're happy to
say that Bob Woodward is here joins us
now live for his first TV interview
about this audio book Bob I spent my
weekend with you and let me tell you
there were several draw dropping moments
listening to the tapes but you end with
this Trump is the wrong man for the job
he is unparalleled unparalleled
unparalleled danger still trying to
overturn election and that he is
consumed by the past unable to let go of
Grievances and lives in his own
self-inflicted melodrama and those tapes
certainly certainly tend to bear that
out but what struck me was the line the
unparalleled danger to the country what
did you mean by that exactly but he
didn't understand the presidency and the
obligations to people he's he's isolated
in himself he has this view that
everything is mine
and he will act uh make key decisions on
Instinct now in the presidency you
president has instincts always you need
to filter them and listen to other
people but you see he is not listening
to people and the clip you played this
idea everything is mine uh
there is a Intimacy in these tapes where
you hear him yes literally saying uh you
know I'm the only one who knows and this
idea that uh you can be president and
only listen to your instincts and make
decisions yeah there's a lot of self in
the presidency Bob there's a whole lot
of self there's a whole lot of self and
you made a point in the tapes of saying
that even when you knew he was not
telling the truth you would let him
continue on and then later on you would
fact check it you would share with the
readers well that's not true he's not
telling the truth this is what actually
happened and now president Trump is
saying that he's going to sue you for
releasing these tapes what is your
response to that
well he says again that this theme
everything is his everything is mine
he's saying these tapes are his and uh
of course he did this voluntarily if
you've listened through these uh Gail
and you see he knows he's being recorded
in fact a number of times he says now
make sure you have your recorder on so
he wants uh this story out but it it's a
tragedy to have somebody who is
president of the United States and does
not think about the people he governs uh
and and so he it has disconnected him
from the responsibility of being
president right Bob you asked president
Trump 600 questions and there were
questions that you pushed back on and
followed up on but you regret regret not
pushing more on one it was how he would
handle a contested election here's that
moment from June 2020.
everyone keeps asking suppose it's a
close election and it's contested what
are you going to do everyone says Trump
is going to stay in the white house if
it's contested have you well I'm not I
don't even comment on that though I
don't want to comment on that at this
time hey Bob I got all these people I'll
talk to you later on tonight
well he tried to shoot you off the phone
um what what did you want to follow up
with him on when again
because that obviously we know is a big
issue he thinks he actually won in 2020
and there's no evidence zero evidence
that he did and I fought myself my
belief for not saying well why is that
what you don't want to comment on in
eight hours of interviews is the only
time he said I don't want to comment and
I should have followed that up and I
didn't and we now know uh that he still
thinks he won in 2020.
uh Bob it's Tony here uh you know the
president of the United States is
whenever he's talking to a journalist
whenever he's being recorded uh he's
speaking for the present but also for
history and I'm curious you've
interviewed a lot of presidents uh first
why did you want to release these tapes
while the president was still alive uh
and also what do you make of the
president's place in history with a
little bit of a time for reflection that
we have left
well this in a way defines part of his
history and uh I've released these
because uh material was used for my
second book on Trump Rage which came out
in 2020 and I earlier this year listened
with my wife Elsa Walsh and assistant
Claire McMullen and we said by God this
is uh this is an emotional truth about
what Trump is doing and it is a level of
irresponsibility and a I asked him once
what's the job of the president and he
said to protect the people and we'd find
him in a tragic tragic way not worrying
not doing anything when they've been
born they're in a very moving way from
his National Security advisors that the
virus is coming and it is a three alarm
on a three alarm fire and yes he covered
up
yeah you could make that five alarm fire
that's one of the things that I found
most troubling with the tapes but I
struggled with this a bit Bob and help
me help me with this I'm not trying to
defend uh president Trump and after
listening to tapes he seems to need one
but if he's and he knows he's being
recorded but is there a difference
between recording with you to give you
you know background for your book and to
make sure everything is accurate and
then to release everything that he said
in a book that's all about the Trump
tapes I struggled with that a little bit
about whether that was the okay or fair
thing to do
well he knew he was being recorded
you listened Gail and he would say now
you got your recorder on me yeah have
you record her um and so he uh this is
history this is real and
um why would I not release it I think
there's an obligation to tell the for
the full story they're they're no it is
it is the whole story so much and uh
let's put it out there and he said when
the book came out he said I said some
great things so yeah and that's what he
kept saying I did great things yeah
no but what you said is it's raw it's
profane it's deceptive it's divisive all
of that is true and it was riveting I
couldn't get enough of it thank you very
much Bob Woodward thank you always good
to have you here the Trump the Trump
tapes you're welcome the Trump tapes
goes on sale tomorrow wherever you like
to buy your books and we'll be right
back